the path to a good idea is through a bad
idea you might
not be agreeable to that you might say
well that seems like a lot of hard work
and frustration heartbreak heartache why
should I do that
what's a great idea begin usually with a
bad idea usually I have to pass through
a lot of bad ideas to get to a great
idea we talked earlier about the rule of
nines says ten for every 10 jokes you
try nine won't work same is true for
ideas you might have 10 ideas for a
sitcom or a screenplay and if you look
at all 10 of them you can just say well
some of these are better than others
which one's the best one at that if you
have 10 ideas and you pick the one you
like best you might not have a great
idea but you know you have the best of
10 ideas that's why it's so important to
generate a lot a lot a lot of ideas most
of them will fall by the wayside in my
vocabulary there's something called a
Monday idea a Monday idea is something
that sounds great on Monday but by the
end of the week you don't even know why
you're so excited about it it's like a
hit song that sounds great at first but
then pretty soon you can't stand it you
realize there's nothing really there we
fall in love with things because they're
new and the great ideas are the ones
that stand the test of time and the
weight of development I'll give you an
example of something that I consider to
be a great idea that it's new to me in
my experience then I'll talk about where
this one came from because they don't
always come from that strategy that I
just gave you I'm walking with a friend
we're walking our dogs
and my friend has a kind of a wild and
and Woolly look about him he's an actor
and he looks a little deranged most of
the time
uh
he's from Kentucky
and I turned to him and I said it I said
you know it'd be a great idea for a
movie Rasputin in Kentucky because you
look like a Rasputin but you're from
Kentucky and you could totally play that
role now I consider that to be a great
idea because it's it takes no effort to
imagine the story around it there's a
governor of the state and he's being
manipulated by some mad Rasputin type
character it's basically the Rasputin
story taken from Zara's Russia and stuck
in rural Kentucky where it's just gonna
work a treat so one way we recognize
good ideas or great ideas is we can see
the the bones of other good ideas on top
of them this race is a point that's
worth raising people who are in the
writing game are very self-conscious
about copying or being thought to copy
or be derivative and that's nearly the
problem that we think it is and I offer
as a as a counter narrative the artist's
experience I'm lately an artist I've
been doing art for a few years now and
I've started to understand that
for many great pieces of art the
conversation starts with I like what I'm
looking at I'm inspired by that I want
to do something like that and there's
never any sense of and I'm copying them
or I'm going into areas that are cliched
or not allowed to me just that artist
painted a beautiful field of poppies I
want to try painting poppies too and
there's no self-consciousness around
copying or turning soil that's already
been turned I would say that a great
idea is not necessarily a new idea or an
original idea a great idea is something
that like I said can stand the weight of
development and stand the test of time
what is a money idea you talked about
Monday ideas what about money what is a
money idea a money idea in my personal
vocabulary is an idea that the minute
you have it you know it's going to work
and you can say I know it's going to
make money
that that just makes it kind of a joke
or a metaphor but uh
let's say you're pitching sitcom ideas
to me I have a series uh I'm gonna make
a sitcom called Rasputin in Kentucky
because why not and now it's a comedy
and you're pitching ideas for Rasputin
like episode ideas Rasputin goes to a
car wash Rasputin uh uh takes up
pickleball and then you say Rasputin
poses in the nude
uh well that's a money idea because the
audience is going to really want to know
that they're not going to see him naked
they know they're never going to but
they know it's going to be an awkward
situation for them they know
instinctively that it's going to be fun
so I as someone who is evaluating ideas
I can look at that and say from here to
that money moment that funny scene I can
see the direct line and that's why I say
money idea and that's why I say let's
put that into development and see if we
can make it happen another idea will
come along that's not a money idea
Rasputin cleans out his closet I don't
know how that's going to be funny until
I know what he finds in the closet
so
it's not yet a money idea but it could
become one I'm going to offer you one
more observation around this
when we see good ideas and somebody
comes along and says the path to a good
idea is through a bad idea
you might
not be agreeable to that you might say
well that seems like a lot of hard work
and frustration heartbreak heartache why
should I do that
because often you cannot get to the good
idea without passing through the bad
idea and I didn't teach this I learned
this from a student of mine very early
in my teaching career adult Learners uh
i s I said you know sometimes you have
to pass through the bad idea to get to
the good one and she said oh it's like
going on a blind date
and I said well what do you mean she
said well
you know he could be horrible but he
might have a cute roommate
and you're never going to meet the cute
roommate if you don't go on a bad blind
date that's true it it ties back into
this notion of having a will to risk
recognizing that bad outcomes are not to
be feared bad outcomes are just outcomes
and in this business that we're in
the currency of the realm is outcomes
the more times we make a thing whatever
that thing is the more quickly and
uh prosperously we progress toward our
goals creativity is carrying buckets to
the river
what is this in eastern philosophy there
is this notion that creativity is
carrying buckets to the river that
there's a river of creativity flowing by
and our job as artists is to dip into
the flow of creativity and see what we
get and that's a valid approach it's
like walking around waiting for a joke
to occur to you or waiting for an idea
to to occur to you you've had these
moments are you walking down the street
and it's like you get hit by lightning
suddenly a great idea appears to you
that's the experience of carrying
buckets to the river and it's good as
far as it goes but it doesn't go far
enough because I don't want to be
creative just in the moment where
creativity takes me by surprise I want
to be creative from nine in the morning
till five at night if I so choose so
carrying buckets to the river isn't
going to be enough I need to build some
irrigation channels I need to throw up a
dam or two I need to use the raw stuff
of creativity more effectively from
moment to moment so when I say carrying
buckets to the river what I'm really
saying is develop a set of tools that
will free you from the magic of
creativity you can benefit from the
magic of creativity it's great to get
hit by that lightning but you don't have
to be a slave to it you don't have to
wait for it to strike as long as you
have strategies for bringing creativity
to you every time you want
I can't tell you how many wonderful
ideas I would get sitting in morning
traffic rush hour traffic could be a
Monday and then the minute you actually
have time to implement them you find a
million things to do to keep yourself
busy
do you know why
it's fear fear okay it's fear resistance
I'm not I don't know if that's true for
you but nine times out of ten when
someone has trouble executing if you
look at it hard enough they're afraid of
the outcome
and you can see this in a lot of
situations having trouble starting and
having trouble finishing are both
manifestations of fear let's look at
having trouble finishing I've written
this novel and it's time for me to do
what Winston Churchill said kill the
Beast and fling it to the public
but I'm afraid I'm afraid of bad
outcomes
I don't know I'm afraid because I'm not
self-monitoring
so I look at what I've written and I say
all the ending doesn't work or this is
all trash I need to go and start over
again I'm not satisfied I'm not going to
release it until it's perfect this is
perfectionism
disguising fear it's fear cloaked as it
needs to be perfect Before I Let It Go
first of all it's never going to be
perfect because nothing is and secondly
the only reason you're afraid to let it
go is not because it's not perfect but
because you're afraid of a negative
outcome
can I tell you about a negative well a
stalled outcome that I've been surfing
now for months
last year I wrote a screenplay a feature
animation for a German client I work
internationally it's in English but it's
for a German client
and I delivered a draft of the
screenplay and it didn't work and I
agreed that it didn't work and I went
back and rewrote it and I delivered it
again day before Halloween
that was uh
four months ago
five months ago and I have not until
today it actually even today haven't
heard one word about whether they like
it or not
and you might say
that's very rude of them
but I just say that's an outcome there
is an outcome out there that I don't
know about and even if I do know about
it it's not going to change how I feel
about myself I'm content to wait today
they emailed me and they said now that
everybody's healthy again oh I didn't
know people were sick we want to have a
meeting on it okay sure let's do that
but now look I'm going into a meeting
where I as a writer have a tremendous
emotional investment in what those guys
say and I have a feeling they wouldn't
be calling this meeting if all they
wanted to say was we love every word of
it put down your tools and you know do a
dance but that would be great but that
seems like an unlikely outcome so I'm
already prospecting the future I'm
already investigating what that meeting
will be like in my mind so that when I'm
in that meeting I can operate
effectively not as a slave to my
emotional reactions but in service of
the work which ultimately is in service
of my ego there's a lot going on I'm
sorry I went around the corner down the
street like I usually do no no that's
fascinating so you waited four or five
months or so haven't heard anything and
now they'd like to call a meeting so all
this time you've been waiting not
knowing where you stood yes but I
haven't been holding on to it the way I
would have held on to it in my youth
this is the important thing I actually
had a friend write a friend called me
the other day you still haven't heard I
still haven't heard must be driving you
insane it's not bothering me at all I'm
not even thinking about it it's an
outcome it's going to be a great outcome
or a bad outcome or an outcome I never
know about but I'm not in the business
of evaluating outcomes I'm in the
business of having new outcomes so if
they say we hate it
never darken our door again I'll say
okay that's the outcome
if I'm hooked on outcome this is another
phrase we can think about people get
hooked on outcome if I'm hooked on
outcome it's because I'm invested in the
outcome leading to new outcomes like if
they love it maybe they'll hire me to
write another one or maybe they'll tell
their friends and they'll hire me I
think a function of being a senior
citizen is that I'm no longer hooked on
outcomes at this point I got I'm playing
with the house is money
and I think that makes it a lot easier
for me to have this tranquility and work
on
work on it as if I were working on any
other tool that I might wish to work
with but that's why I'm writing this
book of practice because when I was
young and freaked out
I needed a book that said to me
explicitly you're just young don't freak
out and that book didn't exist and so or
at least I couldn't find my way to it so
maybe we can consider this to be the
theme of the book of practice you're
just young don't freak out
I think too you have enough sort of uh
roller coaster rides and then you start
to realize oh okay yeah we're just kind
of chugging up the thing here and who
knows what's gonna happen but but I'm
gonna hold on and and I've been down
this I've been on this ride before I've
been on this ride all along and I know
it only has three states up down in
plateau and I actually talk about this I
think in my book creativity rules I talk
about something called Plateau thinking
which says you're only in one of three
states either your life is rising or
it's descending or you're on a plateau
and wherever you are one thing's for
sure you'll be someplace different
you might go from rising to Plateau or
Plateau to Rising again or Plateau to
Falling or falling to Plateau or falling
to Rising but you're always in a change
of state as long as you are engaged in
your practice as long as you're creating
outcomes you're also creating change for
yourself now that's really powerful if
you think about it
all my outcomes even the worst ones
create change Within Me
if that change is positive then it's
growth so now I can look at bad outcomes
and say even if it's a bad outcome and
doesn't Advance my career it's not about
outcome it's a good outcome because it
advances my growth that's a win I can
always take no matter what the other guy
says and again thinking about people who
might be watching this video and and
wanting to engage effectively in their
own creative practice this is the secret
there are no bad outcomes they're only
outcomes that we assign a value to and
we have the choice to assign those
outcomes the value of good outcome bad
outcome or just outcomes and where I try
to stand every day of my life is it's
not a good thing it's not a bad thing
it's just a thing that's taking place
and if I can apprehend it on that level
then no matter what it is I can manage
it more effectively
and of those three states uh sort of the
roller coaster analogy so ascending
descending or plateauing where do you
find your most comfortable
having just been through a plateau
or or a valley I'm not sure how to look
at it uh I would say that that I am
I'm more comfortable with a plateau
State than I was before let me lay it
out for you
through the end of the year I was
engaged in intense labors
and then I finished them and suddenly
everything dropped off I had nothing to
do
and I knew that I needed to take a break
and I knew that I also needed to start
my next project the book of practice
let's not start re-engage with because
it's been around for a while
and I went through a period of about two
weeks where I was saying no to starting
the work
and then one day I said yes to starting
the work and I recognize that's very
common for me when I know I need to
recharge my body tells me because it
just won't let me work and that's what
gets me through those spaces
more broadly
because of how I'm wired when I feel
myself in dissent
I say to myself well of the three
possible States descent is my least
favorite I don't want to be going down I
want to go up I want my life to rise
when I feel myself in dissent again I
try to be mindful of what's going on and
act in a way that will reverse the
situation I can give you a great example
in 2016 my writing practice was broken
it was busted I couldn't write anything
I couldn't sell anything I didn't feel
good about my writing I felt like
uh it's over I'm never going to be
creatively successful again clearly this
is a free fall descent but it wasn't the
first time I've been through this before
I know what it's like to lose my writing
Mojo and I knew from past experience
that the solution was to try something
different that's how I've always gotten
out of the bind in the past but up to
that point it was always try a different
kind of writing and this time I said
it's more major than that I need a more
major change I need to rethink
everything and I made the conscious
decision to take up art knowing that I
didn't know the first thing about art
had no history no practice of it no
expectation of being good at it but I
knew that if I introduced myself to it
it would give me new information that I
could use to reinvigorate my writing so
much so that I ended up writing a book
about the experience of being my first
year in art because the the big hurdle I
hit was I've been a writer all my life I
know how to solve problems creatively
but I haven't been a writer an artist
for five minutes I don't know how to do
anything I'm so uptight what do I do
I said I know I'll go for a white belt
in art because the white belt's the one
they give you for just showing up I
think whatever else I can do I can show
up and then when I heard myself say
those words white belt in Heart Another
Part of my brain said that's a money
idea
because it will give structure to the
work that I'm going to do for the next
year
it will give me the freedom to work
without needing to harvest for a full
year that is to say I give myself
permission to play for a year knowing
that I'm going to take all that
playfulness and turn it into product at
the end and it gave me a great book
called a white belt in art